but most as far as me is Plato and
Aristotle I have to say and the notion
or the possibility of returning to their
thought they were classical philosophers
classical political philosophers
classical means original and it also
means best those two somehow got
together the original is best because
philosophy and political philosophy
after Plato and Aristotle become more
academic more covered over with received
opinion with schools of thought but if
you go back to Plato and Aristotle you
see philosophy as it was getting going
and as it was getting going it somehow
got to be better than it's ever been
since
I'm certainly Australian I have to plead
guilty to that now this happened to me
when I was an undergraduate and just
getting started as a graduate student
about 1953 that was a year that Strauss
brought out his book natural right in
history dry red and was overwhelmed by
later on I'm ed Strauss and he was by
far the most intelligent human being I'd
ever encountered that impressed me I and
I think that he's right on the substance
he made two great points in his thinking
the first the difference between the
moderns and the ancients and the second
was the discovery or the rediscovery of
esoteric thinking that all philosophers
speak to each other on one level and to
their own times on another level so you
always have to read between the lines to
see what they are to try to see what a
philosopher is saying to other
philosophers at his level of competence
as opposed to but also as connected to
what he's saying
say saying to his to the people of his
time
the agents began to political philosophy
and they thought that political
philosophy was essentially centered on
the best regime that would be the best
regime of the common good that we spoke
of earlier the best regime however is
not necessarily actual or even possible
in fact it's utopian it either is very
unlikely or impossible to take place but
still it's the guiding light for the
understanding of politics the moderns
accepted the idea of political
philosophy that this is a necessary
subject perhaps even the crucial subject
for a philosopher but they disagreed on
the best regime they wanted a best
regime that was actual and if it's
actual then the philosopher becomes a
kind of revolutionary so the modern
political philosophers even those like
say John Locke who look rather
conservative to us today were all
fundamentally revolutionaries